so welcome back everybody so we're uh
have now the final session for today
consisting of three shorter
presentations first of which will be by
Catalina on
the past year up which I guess we will
learn what this is without further Ado
thank you uh I don't know first can you
hear me so is it working
everyone thank you for uh and got an
imposter class and uh I will present
here joined work with iron anime SMS
and I will start with trying to explain
what I mean under user propagators and
for this we just first had to take a
look at how such rovers are currently
used
so usually when we use the thoughts over
we have a real life problem we encode it
into pure propositional logic and then
we give this formula to a SAT solver
which will give us either a solution or
a reputation which then can be mapped
back to an answer to our actual real
life question
so for example when we are working in
verification we cannot back the answer
to a potential buggy execution of our
system or if we are interested in some
graph theoretical questions that we can
establish certain Properties by using
the refutation produced by the solver
so this is the most standard case how
such solvers they are used and it's
working pretty well but there are
certain cases then or actual problem is
just simply too large to be expressed in
pure propositional logic or we might
even have constraints which uh
simply just too large let's assume it
now first and also even if we have a
very large formula it's often a case
that only a very tiny portion of it
would have been enough to show that the
formula is unsatisfiable or this might
have certain type of constraints which
can be reasoned about way more
efficiently in other Logics or in other
tools and we see that in these use cases
this standard such flow is not
necessarily the smartest thing but we
can do
so one way how we can address these
problems is to use incremental subsovers
which are allowing us to start with a
partial representation of our problem so
we do not encode the whole problem only
just an initial section of it
and once we give it to a such
incremental starts over based on the
answer of the solver we refine this
representation of the problem by
extending it it further closes
constraints and potentially with
assumptions which we already know
hopefully that they are like temporary
unit closes which are already holding
only one soft query of the
it's over and then we add this excursion
to the exact same start solver which we
used previously which will give us then
a new ones for a bit respect also to
this refinement and we repeat this
refinement Loop until we find a solution
which is indeed solving or actual
problem
so that's the simplest representation to
see how incremental soft servers are
used and we see that this is already
slightly better than the previous case
because we start with a way smaller
formula and even though we saw more than
one South query they are very close to
each other and the thoughts over can
efficiently reason about them so
performance wise we are still good and
we even have these assumptions which are
allowing us to a little bit uh guide the
search of the solver but it is still not
solving completely or problem because
this field might have very very large
problems which we don't even know how to
start learn code and the only way how we
can find the right refinance is to let
the incremental starts over solve our
problem and only at that point we can
see what new constraints we want to add
to our problem
so we can see that in this process the
thoughts over is a completely black box
which means that we don't know what's
happening during search and we also
can't really influence what's happening
there
and with this we arrive to the concept
of user propagators where we have a more
interactive kind of incremental such
reasoning where the start is the same we
start with an initial partial
representation of the problem we give
this formula to an incremental subsoever
we might have the same refinement but
the main difference is that during the
run of the thoughts over we follow what
the solver does and try to influence
this search by adding further
constraints during the search so that's
the basic idea behind user propagators
because the user is participating in the
propagation of the server we will see
later that it's way more than
propagation but that's all we can do
and basically this construction of use
case or this kind of use of such solvers
is very common especially when we are
trying to solve combinatorial problems
or in satisfability module terrorists I
will talk about them a little bit later
but in many other applications as well
like the model annulation or
pre-processing of Microsoft we can see
similar
Solutions but the biggest problem with
this architecture is that it requires
the SATs over to be changed so for this
the user must open up the thoughts over
do some modifications on it so that it
can really during the search interrupt
with the solver and as a result uh the
final tool will really depend on the
current version of the solver and we
can't replace it easily uh and what is
maybe an even bigger problem with this
approach is that modern solvers are very
complex so if we touch them without care
we might introduce bugs into it or we
even doing their performance so that's
the basic issue what we would like to
address in this work and we just simply
suggest to standardize how this
interaction with the subsover should
look like and for this we propose a new
interface which we call
ipas are up I will later on explain a
the name where the main idea is that if
we can agree upon on the standards then
every subsover developer can influence
only this one and as a result the users
will have way easier job to develop
solver Independence applications and
also we have the benefit that suddenly
the start solver is not a black box so
we potentially can have brand new use
cases
and on the technical side of course uh
as a result we have way more green way
to use these Silvers
so how would such a an interface look
like
um as I said already the name is a
little bit uh suggesting how we see this
problem
uh incremental thoughts overs have a
standardized interface already in the
Start Community this is the IPA serve
interface which was introduced in 2016
and this interface is basically focusing
on have to interact with the solver
between solving cost so here we can see
that initially when we are in an unknown
State and we start to build up a formula
by adding Clauses or assumptions or both
and when we have already this initial
representation we ask the solver to
solve it which then will either give us
an answer start or answer in both cases
we can query details about the found
answer either the value of a variables
or
you can check which assumptions were
involved in the find our in the found
unsatisfability and in both cases we can
again add new constraints to the problem
and progress back to the initial unknown
state
so this is how a position IPA server is
interacting or seeing incremental start
solvers and what we suggest is just
simply refine this standard to focus
also on how we can interact with the
solver during this solving books and for
this we have to
uh think about the possible states of
the solver during search and fortunately
in the previous talk we already learned
a lot about how this search during the
start so in the cdcl starts overlooked
like so here I can be a little bit
faster the basic algorithm of CDC are
sovers is that we first do some form of
constraint propagation so we are looking
for unit courses once we have no more uh
literas to propagate the solver must
make a decision so it branches on one of
the variables and then goes back to
propagation and it will be this Loop
until either every variable of the
problem gets assigned which means that
we found the solution and the silver can
return that or one of four Prison
Clauses become fastified and the silver
transistor conflict analysis perfect
analysis we also now learned how how it
looks like in the silver
if we want to very simplify it during
conflict analysis we learned at least
one clause and this one closed via
determine where to backtrack during
search in the search tree of the solver
and in case this learn closes the empty
close the solder can just simply return
and start
so that's a very simplified view on how
CDC has starts over uh behave
and as I said we are trying to find an
interface which allows us to interact
with these states we introduces the
first step on artificial extra stage for
the case when we found the solution and
later with this device is it important
but basically what we would like to
allow the users is to first of all be
aware what's happening in the server so
so to see uh what's happening in this
propagation this region will and beyond
that based on that information be able
to influence the search of the solver
now instead of informally describing one
by one the proposed callback functions I
just prepared one large example that we
hopefully can see how the search can
look like
with this proposed interface
uh so here we have on the left side that
sounds over more precisely we will see
the implication graph of the soft server
which is built during the cdcl loop and
on the right side we have the juicer
which I will call all the time user but
it's actually the ending system with the
thoughts over the tool which is using
the thoughts over as a black box and uh
these two components would like to
interact with with each other and they
can do that through or proposed
interface which has two kinds of
interactions on the left column we will
see possible notifications these are
just positive messages sent to the user
to let you know what's happening during
search and the Callback functions are
the cases where the user is able to
interrupt to give something to the
server
so
when the cdcl loop starts as I said it
always begins with the propagation and
at the very beginning it's a special
propagation because it's without any
kind of decisions so first we have
completely unconditional unit Clauses in
the program and that's what the solver
is looking for here these circles are
representing simply a Silence of
clitoris and then we have an arrow
between them
basically indicates that there is an
implication so by assigning this litera
we got a new unit course which
propagated this literal now when we find
these assignments during the root level
of the search uh the solver first sends
a notification to the user uh stating
that there are these fixed assignments
to be found
picks assignments are very special
because they are as I mentioned already
unconditional they are never undone and
then because of that they are very
important information for the user
because it also means that the real
actual problem can be simplified by
these assignments because even if we
change our assumptions or if we add new
Clauses these assignments will never
change
so this is what first happens and when
the solver runs out of propagation
possibilities the next thing what it
does it can ask the user is there
something to propagate now let's assume
the user says first no then the next
question is is there something to learn
so the idea is that whenever propagation
is over the user has the possibility to
tell if there is something to propagate
or there is some new constraints to be
added to the problem
and uh Industries
and the answer was no so the solver
knows that okay now we have to make a
decision so a new decision level is to
be started but before choosing the
variable based on its own uh how risk as
it normally would happen it can again
Ask the user maybe is there a decision
to be made and let's say in this example
the user says yes please pick you one as
the next decision in that polarity
and then the solver will take this
instead of its own preferred decision
and notifies the user that a new
decision level now officially started
and after that the propagation starts
again because as I mentioned it's
decision propagation looping the search
and all the funds are propagated literas
are also reported to the
loser one tiny detail is that even if
the user does not override the decision
it also has a possibility to fix the
polarity as we saw it in the previous
talk so that's uh also part of the
interface
uh so after propagation is done again we
ask the user is there something to
propagate is there something to learn so
the pattern is very simple
now let's assume that the user answers
no for all of these questions at one
point when the user says yes I would
like to propagate not X
what happens inside the silver at that
point is that we take the current
decision level of the search and we put
there this literal what we just got from
the so uh the user but we can see that
there is no incoming Edge into it
because we don't know what is the reason
of this propagation but it's and we
actually don't even know which level it
belongs so we just put it to the current
one and notify the user that it indeed
got assigned
after that uh now let's assume the
search continues and at a certain point
the user says that there is a close to
be learned in these situations this
Clause can be completely arbitrary so it
can be the empty Clause it can be a
completely irrelevant course it can be a
propagating cause or as in this example
it can be a falsified clause
now if the sober learns the classified
Clause like in this example because
let's assume that we've already
propagated y to be true and actually the
user propagated for us X to be false now
if we learn this close then the solver
immediately translates into a
conflicting state
and it must analyze uh what happened in
this conflict but before doing that we
first have to take care of the external
propagations of the user so the solver
must uh check if every relevant
propagation in the conflict graph is
properly explained or not
and this means that we have to ask the
user for each of the only the useful uh
external propagations what was the
reason close of this propagation step
and when the user gives this RS we can
determine the actual location the actual
assignment level of the propagation and
we can find the proper place to it so to
say in the implication graph and then
the solver must also adjust the
assignment level of those literas which
depended on this assignment so this
requires some extra work on the server
side but the main point that after it it
can fall back to the same profit
analysis and as in the normal UCL
implementations
and once this conflict is analyzed and
the driving process derived the solver
the objective yes so the explanation
will be like a clause or uh yes because
we needed support of conflict analysis
for the resolution so so this is
different of course
um
but what is also important that if we
had other propagations which did not uh
contribute to this conflict they there
are their reasons are not uh learned by
the sovereign
my question was how do you determine the
relevant ones that's simply what is
backward reachable from the conflict
because I could imagine that things very
high up they're not relevant maybe so
yes everything if you want to produce
proofs then you have to ask the user to
explain them because otherwise some
steps of your uh derivation of the
driving closed would miss
my
so everything which is
reachable up until the very root must be
explained okay my feeling would be
everything that you will use for
resolution actually will be is really
needed but other yeah
what you use was propagated by your
clothes which you did not learn so yeah
actually if the output the resolution
proof as important with uh
so what I'm aiming at this might there
not be things that you do not use for
resolution that you're now explicitly
asking explanations for so are you sure
that you need all of them so I don't
need them sorry I don't need them for
the conflict analysis but I need them to
be sure that the produce proof has
everything so that's that's uh
so so technically I will not touch those
those explanations which are on Lower
decision levels so it's it's the same
with closed and minimization
but I think for the produce proof to be
surely correct uh you need all of these
explanations
but so that's a good question I I
if somebody has also experience with
this I have another question why don't
you ask for explanations right away the
person I would need to learn it and it
often happens that if I find a solution
I want to use these propagations but I
don't want to learn the related
questions
yeah but then I would need to store them
somewhere I would need to remember I
would as I said it and the user has to
do the same right yeah but the user
knows why why he propagated it I well I
I mean the user would store the
propagation I mean the explanations I
think because otherwise it might be
cheaper to just reproduce the place on
the trail because you know the trail
also when you ask for Direction
so the user may it might take the user
some time to generate these explanations
even though they can reproduce them so
this happens in crypto mini software
it's actually eventually expensive to
generate the explanation but I can
always recover it so I just give a sort
of a placeholder to the set solver and
then when the the soft server needs it
because you know it's part of the
conflict analysis then I produce it it's
magically pops out of there but but it's
this is I think a lazy uh
whichever way you want to call it makes
it's quite good otherwise it's eager
right that's the other and by the way
the related to the conflict analysis I
think that was asked here
um I mean Randall and me had to figure
this thing out at one point for uh this
proof generating uh golf show
denomination
and uh it's not that easy yeah but it
also depends on the system
we had to stitch it together with the
five descriptor with that I mean maybe
Reynolds better at this but we stitched
it together with the radio file
descriptor and a and a shared uh integer
that that incremented the um the the the
the the close IDs because we were using
crop which just goes like this
um yeah but the 500 is still a pain
sometimes because you really have you
can't do this delayed writing that like
some of the sub servers do because of
course the other the other thread well
the other uh not thread actually but the
other thing might just write to it and
then you're like it's all going to be
all messed up like I figure this out but
that conclusion was also for you you
needed also the higher ones which were
not participating explicitly in the
conflict analysis but you still kept the
reason of um
uh so at one point the user gives us an
explanation that's agree upon it at
least the interface supports to us the
user for an explanation it's up to the
developer to decide to ask if there is
something to explain and uh based on the
conflict analysis then uh as we so at
least one close will be learned which
will drive the backtracking that's not
going to which level but at one level
this solver will decide to backtrack and
about this again a notification is sent
to the user so it can simulate what
happened with the trail
and again propagation can continue yes
can you decide where to backtrack sorry
can the user decide where to backtrack
to choose a decision level no no because
that would be pretty uh tricky to
guarantee that the user is the risk
least Reliable Parts in this position
it's already treat you have to handle
when the user propagates Faster by
literas and the user has one let's say A
Satisfied Clause as a reason of
propagation so so there are already
enough things for the user can
do in a very bad way and that would be
not a good idea
so
after propagation and research at one
point let's say the solver hopefully
finds a solution and then the very last
callback comes into game and we can ask
simply the user if the phone solution is
accepted
and it just user says no Then uh he or
she has the possibility to provide new
propagations and new Clauses to drive
the search for somewhere else but very
important that at that point the solver
will not restart just simply backtrack
based on the learned information from
the user
so all in all uh they proposed uh for
notification functions and five callback
functions and we argue that with these
very minimalistic interface we can
capture a very wide range of
applications
um so what I showed here functions are
not new as we can agree on it for
example Kringle and intercept all
support to learn Clauses during the
search City solvers are very familiar
with lazy explanation Lasik host
generation techniques and maybe the
oldest
implementation of these functions can be
found in smts or more precisely in the
search over so fast overs so we can see
that these concepts are not brand new
and they are widely used but still there
is no standard about how to do it so
that's our goal to solve
and to show that what we propose here is
a viable option we extend that particle
state of the art sets over with this
proposed interface and evaluated it into
representative use cases
the first one is the combinatorial
combinatorial problem uh called sub
modular symmetries and I will not talk
about it uh too much because tomorrow
Stefan cider will hopefully probably
describe it later than I could do it uh
here I just show the very first
experiment where we just simply want to
enumerate every particular graph but we
can find over and vertices such that
each of them are known as amorphic to
each other and for this we basically
look for graphs with minimal HSN
symmetrics which can be encoded into
such but would require an exponential
amount of additional causes but instead
of this explicit including we can use
our interface and add these minimality
courses only on demand when it would be
necessary to avoid if we find a
previously discovered graph
or a non-mineral graph to be precise and
here you can see the running times
what we just can see here that we can
find uh very quickly like 12 million
graphs with the proposed interface and
it really gives us a significant speed
up
but as I said I will not go more into
the details of this experiment the other
experiments that we did is in the
context of satisfability module or
terrories where we would like to decide
the satisfability of the first order
formula with respect to some background
theories uh like a rose boots vectors or
arithmetics and this is very important
in the domain of verification synthesis
and other applications
and most of these solvers are following
this so-called cdcrt approach where we
have a leading thoughts over considering
the Boolean abstraction of the program
and we have a set of terrorist solvers
which are interacting with these
thoughts over and The Guiding and
guaranteeing that the phone solution
will be indeed consistent with the
oxygons of the underlying background
terrorist
and in this experiment we basically
showed that we don't propose the
interface we can actually capture every
necessary interaction in such an SMP
solver and for that we use this
interface in cdc5 which is a
state-of-the-art
um
and some things don't work that supports
our background terrorists and their
combinations
and which has also many
functionalities Beyond smt but what is
technically the most important for us it
is a solver which is highly tuned and
customers for a very specific version of
ministat which is a very old subsover
but with all new interface it was
possible to replace many thoughts with a
particle
and uh it wasn't easy but still it was
the resulting in a state where now we
have an smt solver where you can
basically plug in any thoughts over
which implements this interface so
that's definitely something which is uh
very encouraging and also
performance-wise we found that many many
instances many new instances got sold
and in many terrorists several
terrorists the speed that was very
significant
so to sum it up we proposed the general
interface which allows us to inspect and
influence the CDC as search of set
solvers it meant to be simple and
flexible hopefully it's easy to
implement in modern thought solvers but
at the same time it's sufficient to
capture many use cases we implemented it
in a model representative sets over
thoughts over which is even does
in-processing and we evaluated this
extended version of the solver uh where
we showed that it indeed captures the
necessary interactions for a very wide
range of use cases
uh in the future uh we would like to
exploit even more that now we can have
in processing during user propagation
and of course uh the most important most
urgent next step is to think about
proofs that have incremental improcesses
improves should look like what
information should they contain and to
what to do with these externally coming
closes from the user in the produced
proofs and that was what I wanted to
show you here thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
questions for Catholics
regarding in processing did you turn off
variable elimination
so uh now it's a lot to in-process
everything which is not changed by the
user so it's like the classical old
school influences you can't remove what
we said because then the user can may
just ask to decide on that one yeah so
that's uh one thing what we I mean
decision
could be tricky yes but uh so one thing
I didn't mention we we constrain the set
of variables based on what the user and
the server is communicating and then you
just freeze those words yes yes now we
freeze them but Intel really know that
how we could emphasize the interests and
practices
oops
so uh great work um I'm really looking
forward to using it I've already the
incremental interface has been extremely
useful
um uh so the question I have so
regarding your loss points proofs did
you think about what you need from
proofs so for example I also discussed
it with Curtis
um so maybe just have a say a trust so
you have the new line look at this close
you can trust
and if you don't know it yet but I can I
can explain it other things you might
need for proofs that that in this
setting
yes that's what I I meant under it that
we we have to think about how how this
external Clauses should look like and
what the user maybe the user could keep
the proof for them or we just in the
proof introduce something which notice
that that's coming in yeah because you
can imagine that you have them in your
proof and that the support just trust
them of the Checker trust and then what
tries to minimize that
[Music]
once in your actual proof and then you
only have to figure out
a lot of options
thank you
so can I uh see this user interaction as
a theory solver as well like
uh in the smt like if it would be like
you can propagate and
explain so it's there is like a
technique like in smt which
if I'm correct or not but lemmas on
demand where you don't explain right
away
but when you need to explain for the
conflict analysis then the theory solver
will produce yes the the Clause so
that's the exact same right so that
could be the way when where you can be
lazy as yes
so also in our experimental smt solver
very heavily relied on this lazy
explanation and uh and also on the other
functionalities of the interface okay
it's the same yes thank you
I think we should move on to the next
stop so let's thank
[Applause]
foreign
distribution